this week will mark the one-year
anniversary of the beginning of the
Trump administration yet still the never
ending Russia investigation grinds on
Steve Bannon was just subpoenaed to
appear before a special counsel Robert
molars grand jury he also testified
today before the House Intelligence
Committee Bannon refused to answer the
committee's questions about his time at
the White House that prompted committee
members to subpoena him on the spot
congressman trey Gowdy of South Carolina
was there and he joins us tonight come
from Mexico I went up yes sir thank you
so de Bannon admit being a Russian agent
what we learn we learned about a new
privilege that before today did not
exist it's an executive privilege that
covers transition communications
communications while you're working at
the White House and then communications
after you separate from service at the
White House so that's why the subpoena
was issued it's because it is the most
tortured analysis of executive privilege
I have ever heard so when you make very
provocative claims like treason and
unpatriotic and there's a zero percent
chance that these Russian loggers
weren't walked up to then see candidate
Trump that then you're going to be asked
about it and you're going to be asked a
lot about it and that's what we tried to
do today but does anyone believe those
claims are true I mean I'm sort of
losing track of the point of this whole
exercise does anybody on Capitol Hill
think the Trump campaign colluded with
the Russian government in order to
subvert our democracy well I can't speak
for my friends on the other side of the
aisle Adam Schiff said he had evidence
of collusion before we even started yeah
I have seen no evidence of collusion
between the Russians and President Trump
between the Russians in the Trump
campaign but it was Steve banned' who
used the word treasonous and it was
Steve and he used the word unpatriotic
those are two pretty serious accusations
to level particularly at the president
son so you're going to be asked about it
and and he also needed to be asked about
things that happen with respect to Comey
the reason we had a little hiccup this
morning was because executive privilege
now covers things before you become the
chief executive which is just
mind-numbing and there's no legal
for it but we can't make a witness
answer a question so you've been in the
middle of this investigation for a long
time what's your conclusion do you think
your Democratic colleagues are acting in
good faith I'm not good at judging
people's motives I can tell you having
been around Congress for seven years
there's a built-in advantage for the
Democrats and dragging this out as long
as they possibly can and that we're
really really reticent to start so once
you are reticent to start that tells me
that you don't have an end date they
want this dragged through the 2018
elections they want to retake the house
it is our responsibility to conduct this
thorough and investigation as we can but
also do it in the most expedited way
that we can it'd be really helpful if
the Democrats wanted to get started a
little sooner
like in March or April this year but
they didn't so that's the politics but
quite frankly Tucker I don't think any
of your viewers are holding their breath
waiting on what a congressional
investigation uncovers I think they're
waiting on Bob Muller
because his investigation carries more
credence with them than ours does well
the whole thing just seems so stupid to
me I mean I'm willing to believe
wrongdoing you know you know on a lot of
levels by a lot of people the Russian
collusion seems unproven I wonder just
hypothetically if this roles were
reversed and Democrats held all the
levers of power do you think Republicans
would be able to do what Democrats have
done which is drive this investigation
from the beginning no I can tell you
firsthand we will not be able to do that
because when President Obama was in
office we had an impossible time getting
access to documents and witnesses when I
was leading another investigation but
the biggest headwind of all was at
President Obama it was the media the
mainstream media could give a damn less
about what happened in Benghazi they're
really really interested in what
happened in Russia in part because they
don't know anybody that voted for Donald
Trump so they're still trying to figure
out how this election occurred and how
his election occurred so the mainstream
media is the biggest difference to me
between the investigation I did a couple
years ago and the one we're doing now
yeah it sure seems that way congressman
thanks all for coming on for that update
sir